marcel geiger und sein kumpel wollen am
wochenende einfach nur kochen und musik
hören doch plötzlich stehen acht
polizisten in der küche auf der
gästeliste standen die natürlich nicht
er war ab so beklemmend und schockiert
dass so was in deutschland passiert wir
haben rechtsstaat und kein polizeistaat
wir waren wirklich erschrocken und
hatten den ganzen abend
was war passiert an einem freitagabend
anfang märz treffen sich marcel geidel
und sein kumpel musikhören essen
bierchen alles coroner regelkonform zwei
haushalte in einer wohnung das ist
erlaubt sogar 19 10 mein freund bist du
draußen auf der terrasse zum rauchen und
ich war weiter in der küche ein paar
sachen vorbereitet zu unserem koch
abends ohne seitlich völlig verwundert
dann läutete licht durch die hecke zum
friedhof und ganz hell und
wir erschrocken richtig kurz darauf
steht das ordnungsamt vor der tür der
vorwurf ruhestörung und die vermutung
dass gegen die korona schutz verordnung
verstoßen wird gegenüber dem ordnungsamt
sollen die zwei freunde geäußert haben
dass sie noch eine zweistellige anzahl
von personen erwarten deshalb steht
wenige minuten später die polizei vor
der tür statt der beiden freunde tummeln
sich plötzlich acht polizisten in voller
montur um den herd die szenerie wirkt
auf die zwei bedrohlich und irgendwie
unverhältnismäßig
die polizei gibt daraufhin folgendes
statement ab das ordnungsamt ging davon
aus dass in dem haus eine größere anzahl
von menschen zu einer feier
zusammengekommen sei sie konnten außer
den beiden augenschein nicht leicht
alkoholisierten männern keine weiteren
personen feststellen
gegen 20 uhr rückt das einsatzkommando
ab als die beamten das haus verlassen
hatten beleidigte der 41-jährige sie
unter anderem als rechtsextreme
polizisten deshalb stellten die
eingesetzten beamten strafantrag wegen
beleidigung erklärt die polizei das war
bestimmt von hier ist völliger quatsch
und ich denke das als schutzbehauptungen
weil sie ganz genau wissen dass hier was
gemacht wird auch so weiter nicht
abfinden würden die frage ob dieses
riesige polizeiaufgebot wirklich nötig
war bleibt
mobile geschichte und tatsächlich gibt
es jetzt einen prozess und heute ist er
prozesstag in diesem fall und unser
reporter michael engelberg städte
zusammen mit den angeklagten am amts-
und landgericht in essen michael
ja guten morgen aus essen nach berlin ja
tatsächlich thomas du hast gesagt heute
beginnt der prozess am amtsgericht mit
herrn guy de herr geiger wir haben
gerade noch einmal die bilder gesehen es
waren sehr sehr skurriler abend der
eigentlich anders geplant war wenn sie
jetzt noch mal zurück denken wir stehen
zusammen in ihrer küche was geht ihnen
da durch den kopf ja ich war schockiert
also wir hatten den kochabend zu zweit
geplant dann wirklich so wir beide
anwesend völlig corona konform und
plötzlich fällt da um kurz vor acht die
polizei ein angeblich wie einer
ruhestörung in mannschaftsstärke mit
zehn leuten ja das bin immer noch
schockiert und kann überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen dass ich jetzt auch der
angeklagte sein soll sie wohnen
gegenüber eines friedhofs da kommt von
der einen seite nicht ganz so viel lärm
vielleicht aus dem haus aber
letztendlich muss man ja auf sie
aufmerksam geworden sein wie erklären
sie sich das der grund ist relativ
einfach mittlerweile weiß ich dass es
auf dem friedhof gab sendungen wohl von
jugendlichen der vergangenheit deswegen
hat das ordnungsamt dort
ein rundgang gemacht und es dann halt
auf unsere musik aufmerksam geworden die
aber gar nicht laut war ja von dices
unfassbar ja auch zu der uhrzeit immer
vorstellen es war 19 uhr herr
freitagabend das ist noch relativ früh
führen freitagabend aber für alle die
jetzt nicht dabei war sie stehen da
haben sie vielleicht ein gläschen wein
in der hand einer roten bisher im
kochtopf und dann plötzlich besuch der
nicht angekündigt war wie haben wir uns
ja fast ich werde ja gut werden die tür
aufgemacht und was die presse das
ordnungsamt der dann kam die polizei
nach und wir sagten mit zehn leuten und
meinen mein freund war da an einer tür
hat die tür aufgemacht und plötzlich
stand nie bei mir mit acht leuten in der
wohnung ich kann es nicht begreifen dass
hausfriedensbruch ehrlich gesagt also
dass das so was in deutschland passiert
ist ist ein skandal
jetzt muss man sich das vorstellen die
waren nicht angekündigt die die leute
die haben die haben natürlich auch ihre
arbeit gemacht aber welche dynamik
entwickelte sich denn da plötzlich
meinen sie wollten ja eigentlich nur
einen schönen abend verleben zuerst das
ordnungsamt da wir haben sollte ich
erschrocken die leute durch die
friedhofs hecke
werden etwas kann nicht wahrgenommen das
wäre ein scherz ja um die uhrzeit
während passant der sich uns erlaubt
dann stand er plötzlich vor der tür
wollten die ausweise haben zwischendurch
war dann schon mal anwalt zugeschaltet
aber ich glaube das passiert das geht
hier eigentlich ab und er sagt wir sind
nicht verpflichtet dem ordnungsamt die
ausweise auszuhändigen und man kann die
polizei plötzlich damit gesagt mit zehn
leuten also ich bin immer noch
schockiert ja also wirklich was da
passiert es ist nicht absolut
nachvollziehbar nichtsdestotrotz heute
ist ihre verhandlungen erst mal in einer
halben stunde beginnt das da wird die
anklage vorgelesen mit welchem gefühl
gehen sie denn jetzt heute rein wenn sie
nochmal auf diesen kochan blicken der
eigentlich schön gedacht und jetzt ja
sind sie angeklagt mit sehr gemischten
gefühlen ehrlich gesagt also diese
ungerechtigkeit die man da halt
empfindet auf der einen seite oft an
diese unsicherheit wenn man vom gericht
auf noch vorsehe weiß man alleine ist
mein gottes hand aber ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass auch die zeugen dann
entsprechend bekräftigen können dass da
eben und von unserer seite von meiner
seite nichts passiert ist und auch die
veröffentlichung des bildmaterials muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen was mir auch
angelastet wird das video das hat über
bild kann ich auch nicht nachvollziehen
die polizisten sind natürlich auch
geschult zu solchen situationen zu
kommen aber
welche dynamik entstanden da wie war
denn dass die gesprächsatmosphäre also
sie sind ja eigentlich wegen einer
ruhestörung gekommen und wenn man sich
das anguckt und anhört es war eigentlich
irgendwie zimmer lautstärke und leise
genau die musik war war völlig ausser
dem verbreiten dass die polizei da war
es war lag eine ruhestörung hervor in
keinster weise auch die nachbarn können
das bezeugen das sieht man im prozess
auch dann dann hören
ja also man muss einfach sagen es hat
eine dynamik genommen und wie gesagt ich
habe auf meinen anwalt per telefon dabei
und der einsatzleiter wo er hat
abgelehnt mit meinem anwalt zu
telefonieren zu sprechen und wir waren
sieht man auch in dem video was ich was
ich zur führung gestellt habe eigentlich
relativ ruhig wenn man bedenkt was da
gerade passiert ist das darf ja nicht
vergessen
ja ihr habt in berlin gehört herr guy de
versucht trotzdem durch diesen tag zu
kommen er erinnert sich natürlich daran
was passiert ist in einer halben stunde
beginnt der prozess und dann werden wir
sehen wie die ganze sache ausgeht ob das
verfahren eingestellt wird oder ob man
eventuell mit einer strafe rechnen kann
zurück nach berlin
[Musik]